I was shot about 16 years ago and I
still feel the effects from that day in
every aspect of my life
[Music]
I was working as a camp counselor when I
was 16 years old at the North Valley
Jewish Community Center one day after
playing capture the flag I was walking
in with one of my favorite campers we
decided to walk to the front of the
building because that's where the rest
of my campers were who were all five and
six year old kids and as we walked to
the front of the building a man walked
in carrying a semi-automatic hoozy
replica gun and started shooting and he
shot off about 70 rounds of ammunition
into the building he shot me first and
then he just started spraying he showed
up on a day where there were a lot of
children there about 350 kids at the
Jewish Community Center so I grabbed
James and I ran into a classroom that
was right in front of us and there were
a bunch of little kids five and six
years old in that room with my co
counselors and I was covered in blood
and we still heard shooting outside
bang bang bang the campers all looked up
at me and kept saying what's all over
Mindy what's all over Mindy there
happened to be an emergency exit in that
one room that we went into we ran
outside there was a glass sliding door
behind us and he saw us running and shot
through the glass door and the glass
exploded behind us I had lost a lot of
blood at that point and couldn't
continue running so we closed our eyes
and played dead until we heard sirens
and to this day I still have quite a bit
of shrapnel inside my leg and it's a
constant reminder of what I went through
the thing that I remember most is when
you breathe in you feel air inside your
lungs but you've never felt air anywhere
else inside your body and immediately
after the bullets passed through me I
remember feeling invisible because there
was air running through me that I had
never felt before
and that's the instant that I knew
something a wasn't right
B I had been shot and the moment where I
started thinking about death he shot
three five-year-old kids myself who was
16 at the time and a 65 year old woman
who was the receptionist the ones that
weren't shot they are you know in their
20s now and are continuing to have
horrific nightmares about this bad man
with a gun coming in trying to take
their lives away a year later I tried to
go away to college and I had a complete
breakdown within the first six days of
being there a kid walked down the hall
with a nerf gun and he was just you know
having fun laughing and and shooting
everybody with nerf balls and the second
the Nerf ball hit me I broke down they
put me in a psych ward of a hospital and
I felt crazy so I typically have a panic
attack every time I see a mass shooting
Virginia Tech immediately after I had a
panic attack Sandy Hook instantly panic
attack and I know moving forward I will
continue to have the reactions like I do
what scares me is not having the
reaction it scares me
when we become numb people always tell
me that I was in the wrong place at the
wrong time but in reality I was in the
right place at the right time I was 16
you know I was working with my little
kids I was protecting my kids and our
future as a society and so how dare you
tell me I was in the wrong place at the
wrong time he was in the wrong place at
the wrong time
I think it happened to me for a reason I
don't think there are a lot of people
that could have handled what happened to
me as well as I have I've definitely
suffered emotionally I continue to
suffer I'm 33 I'm married I own a home I
live in a wonderful wonderful city and I
couldn't be happier and had I not been
shot all of those things probably
wouldn't necessarily have happened to me
but yeah I would take it away I don't
put this on anybody but if it could have
happened anybody I am glad it happened
to me because nobody deserves to go
through that kind of pain
[Music]